pam would you smell my breath no no let
me smell
good not great
yes
a word of advice speaking as a former
baby security in this office park is a
joke last year i came to work with my
spud gun in a duffel bag
i sat at my desk all day with a rifle
that shoots potatoes at 60 pounds per
square inch
can you imagine if i was deranged ryan
cost thunder mifflin hundreds of
thousands of dollars michael ryan david
i don't care if ryan murdered his entire
family he is like a son to me
freak i need a favor well then you have
to call me by my name gabriel susan
lewis what if meredith was taking her
smoking break below that window you know
what would have happened
the shards of glass would have shaved
her face right off and yes it might have
been funny but it also would have been
incredibly tragic so when
when did you set up shop i opened this
place after i came back from vietnam oh
vietnam i hear it's lovely
someone complained that the men's room
is whites only
stanley you know that's not true i
didn't say that and why is there a
picture of a white man on the door
well i managed my department and i've
been doing that for several years now
and god i've learned a lot of life
lessons along the way
your department's just you right yes jim
but i am not easy to manage r is among
the most menacing of sounds that's why
they call it murder and not mukduck okay
too many different words coming at me
from too many different sentences i'm
always thinking one step ahead
like a
carpenter
that makes stairs
hey
right back at you [ __ ]
meredith what are you doing i could be
pregnant okay no oh my resolution was to
get more attention
nope she's lying i am a huge woody allen
fan
although i have only seen ants but i'll
tell you something what i respect about
that man is that when he was going
through all of that stuff that came out
in the press
about how ants was just a ripoff of a
bug's life he stayed true to his films
or at least the film that i saw which
again was ants
thing is
i thought bug's life was better much
better than ants
point is
don't listen to your critics
listen to your fans
you okay
i am better than you have ever been or
ever will be
toby is in hr which technically means he
works for corporate so he's really not a
part of our family
also he's divorced so he's really not a
part of his family
what is the most inspiring thing i ever
said to you
don't be an idiot changed my life
whenever i'm about to do something i
think would an idiot do that and if they
would i do not do that thing
hey hey hey i got your text who's
phillip no no no who tipped you over was
it philip this'll be easy
so just like rearrange the buttons and
stuff yeah yeah like when you press his
door closed the door's open or he
presses lobby it goes the third floor
stuff like that can you do that yeah let
me take a look at the circus board
call froggie 101
say that we're the tour manager for
justin bieber and we're giving away free
tickets we give him a number to call for
the tickets and it's his number who is
justice beaver
he it's a crime-fighting beaver once
upon a time we were natural enemies but
we've overcome our differences much like
germany and italy in world war
good call
together we run a no-nonsense office
hey do you want to tell stanley that i
have asthma because i don't
if it gets out they won't let me scuba
if i can't scuba then what's this all
been about what am i working toward
you don't have all the facts which are i
love them
oh god
how far has it gone
no
no he's my nephew you don't have all the
facts which are
i love him
oh god
how far is it gone
no
no he's my nephew smile no
i never smile if i can help it showing
one's teeth is a submission signal in
primates when someone smiles at me all i
see is a chimpanzee begging for its life
if i had a gun with two bullets and i
was in a room with hitler bin laden and
toby i would shoot toby twice
okay all right really funny and then you
went too far mistletoe is not an excuse
for sexual assault seriously you're
gonna send them back
uh yeah that's the safest part of a car
in the event of a crash driver always
protects his side first
yes i have a dream and it's not some mlk
dream for equality
i want to own a decommissioned
lighthouse
and i want to live at the top
and nobody knows i live there
and there's a button
that i can press
and launch that lighthouse
into space
ultimatums are key basically nobody does
anything for me anymore unless i
threaten to kill myself
look at where you're going to be doing
the cartwheel so look where you're going
to be placing your hands so pick a spot
you ready to do this yes sir you know
what i'm going to stay here as long as
it takes i really appreciate it i'm
gonna spot you i spot you you don't
go
i did it
you did the perfect cartwheel
okay good
no rush that's all i had to do all year
congratulations
all right well
all right see you tomorrow finally broke
down and bought myself
a plasma
tv
check it out i actually hung this on the
wall myself it's good i want to show you
something a lot of people in the room
you need more space
voila right into the wall wow
we are not always going to be there
to coddle your heart back
when it disappears to be working
what are you gonna do if you're by
yourself and your heart stops
i would die
and you're okay with that i'm okay with
the logic of it no no
jim you're six eleven
and you weigh 90 pounds gumby has a
better body than you
boom roasted dwight you're a kiss ass
boom roasted pam you failed art school
boom roasted meredith you've slept with
so many guys you're starting to look
like one boom roasted kevin i can't
decide between a fat joke and a dumb
joke boom roasted creed your teeth
called your breath stinks boom roasted
angela where's angela
well there you are i didn't see you
behind that grain of rice boom
roasted stanley you crush your wife
during sex and your heart sucks boom
roasted oscar you
are
oscar
you're gay
wow andy cornell call they think you
suck
and you're gayer than oscar
oh roasted
you